لماذا يقدم الكونفدرالية الإسرائيلية الفلسطينية الأردنية
الحل الواقعي الوحيد للصراع الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني الذي دام
75 عامًا من
الصراع بغض النظر عن التغييرات العديدة
على الأرض والرياح السياسية التي
اجتاحت المنطقة
والعنف المتقطع بين إسرائيل
والفلسطينيين مما أدى إلى
إسرائيل المأساوية  حرب حماس
لن يتخلى الفلسطينيون عن تطلعهم إلى
إقامة دولة، حيث إن المجموعات العديدة
التي تم إنشاؤها على الأرض
منذ
عام 1967 تجعل إنشاء كونفدرالية إسرائيلية
فلسطينية أردنية
أمرًا ضروريًا لتحقيق
سلام إسرائيلي فلسطيني مستدام.
لماذا
يتم تعريف الكونفدراليات
كما هو مقتبس، رابطة
الدول المستقلة الطوعية، من أجل تأمين بعض
الأغراض المشتركة، توافق على
قيود معينة على حريتها في العمل
وتنشئ EST آلية مشتركة
للتشاور أو المداولات. نهاية
الاقتباس هناك خمس حقائق رئيسية على
أرض الواقع تطورت منذ عام 1967
6  حرب يومية لم يعد من الممكن
تغييرها بشكل كبير مما يجعل إنشاء
الكونفدرالية أمرًا حتميًا،
حرب إسرائيل مع حماس جعلت ذلك أكثر أهمية
اليوم مما كان عليه قبل انتشار الإسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين في
الضفة الغربية والقدس وإسرائيل
والأردن مما يجعل من المستحيل ببساطة
التواجد فعليًا  نقل شريحة كبيرة
من
السكان: هناك ما يقدر بنحو 3
ملايين فلسطيني و700000
إسرائيلي في الضفة الغربية
والقدس الشرقية، ونحو 2 مليون مواطن عربي إسرائيلي، و
2.3 مليون فلسطيني في
غزة، و50% من سكان الأردن
من
أصل فلسطيني بسبب التركيبة السكانية.
لا يمكن تغييره بأي طريقة مهمة،
فهو يجعل التعايش بين الإسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين والأردنيين أمرًا لا
مفر منه. ثانيًا، يشكل الأمن القومي الإسرائيلي
وشعور الفلسطينيين
بعدم الأمان مصدر قلق كبير
لجميع الأطراف،
خاصة وأنهم مرتبطون بشكل مباشر،
وبالتالي فإن
التعاون الأمني ​​أمر أساسي في أي
اتفاق سلام.  وحتى الآن هناك تعاون أمني واسع النطاق
يشمل تبادل المعلومات الاستخبارية
والتنسيق
الذي يجب توسيعه بشكل أكبر.
تحت مظلة
الكونفدرالية، يجب أن يرتكز أي اتفاق سلام
على
تعاون أمني قوي بين
الأطراف الثلاثة. القدس الثالثة فريدة من نوعها من حيث وجود
الإسرائيليين الفلسطينيين
والأردنيين واليهود.  المسلمون
والمسيحيون في جميع أنحاء العالم لديهم
صلة خاصة بالمدينة القدس
فهي موطن أقدس مزار لليهود وثالث
أقدس المزارات الإسلامية وأقدس
جوانب
المسيحية نظرا لأن هذه
المزارات المقدسة متجاورة مع بعضها البعض
ولا يمكن أن يحدث أي تغيير مادي  ستكون هناك
دائمًا الحاجة إلى التعاون الكامل
في مجال الأمن والتحسينات في جميع
الأماكن المقدسة، بالإضافة إلى أن القدس الشرقية تضم
أكبر مجتمع يهودي عربي مختلط في
أي مكان في العالم مع ما يقرب من
330.000 عربي و
215.000 يهودي يتنقلون بحرية في جميع أنحاء
المدينة وإسرائيل و  لا
يريد أي من الطرفين تغيير ذلك بموجب أي
اتفاق سلام، فالبنية التحتية للمدينة
والخدمات والطرق والشبكة الكهربائية
والاتصالات
والصيانة متكاملة تمامًا. وبغض النظر عن مدى
حق عودة
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين، فمن
المستحيل ببساطة ممارسة مثل هذا الحق بالنظر إلى
تغيير الواقع على الأرض
بدلاً من ذلك، يجب على الفلسطينيين إعادة تعريف
حق العودة إلى دولة
فلسطين بشكل عام والذي يتماشى
مع المبادئ القانونية الدولية.
حل
قضايا اللاجئين يعتمد إذن كما هو الحال دائمًا على
التعويض أو إعادة التوطين في الغالب
في الغرب  الضفة وغزة وتقديم
تعويضات لأولئك الذين يعيشون خارج
الأراضي الفلسطينية وخاصة أولئك الذين يعيشون
في سوريا ولبنان والعراق ويختارون عدم
النقل. ستبقى الغالبية العظمى من
المستوطنين في مكانهم لأنه لن توافق أي
حكومة إسرائيلية بغض النظر عن
ميولها السياسية على
إزالة المستوطنين.  على
النحو المتفق عليه في مفاوضات السلام السابقة
في 2008 و9 و2013 و
14، سيتم تعويض الفلسطينيين
من خلال مبادلة الأراضي بنسبة 4 إلى 6% للتعويض
عن الأراضي التي تستخدمها المستوطنات الإسرائيلية
في
الضفة الغربية، وخاصة من خلال
كتلة المستوطنات الثلاث الكبيرة.  على طول
حدود عام 1967، لماذا يجب أن ينضم الأردن إلى
الاتحاد الكونفدرالي الفلسطيني الإسرائيلي لأسباب عديدة بما في ذلك
الأمن القومي الأردني،
ومخاوف قربه من إسرائيل
والضفة الغربية،
وتكوينه الديموغرافي، وعلاقاته التجارية مع
كل من إسرائيل والفلسطينيين،
وحقيقة أن الأردن هو الوصي على إسرائيل.
الحرمين الشريفين في القدس
ويعيش بسلام مع إسرائيل، كل ذلك يجعل من
الأردن المركزي ثالث دولة مستقلة
في
الكونفدرالية، حيث قال إنه لا يمكن تحقيق واستدامة أي
اتفاق على إنشاء
كونفدرالية
إلا إذا سبقته
عملية
مصالحة بين إسرائيل.
والفلسطينيون لمدة لا تقل عن 7 إلى 10 سنوات،
ستتضمن هذه العملية
تفاعلات شاملة بين الحكومة والشعب والشعب
للتخفيف من العائق النفسي
وانعدام الثقة
والكراهية المتجذرة بينهما، بالإضافة إلى أن العوامل
الاجتماعية والاقتصادية والأمنية هي
متطلبات مسبقة للحفاظ على الوحش.
يجب على الأطراف الثلاثة أن تتفق
منذ البداية على أن مثل هذه العملية يجب أن
تؤدي في نهاية المطاف إلى إنشاء
دولة فلسطينية كشرط
أساسي لإنشاء
كونفدرالية إسرائيلية فلسطينية أردنية.
إنشاء كونفدرالية
سيضمن قيام إسرائيل بتأمين ديمقراطيتها
وهويتها القومية اليهودية.
يحقق الفلسطينيون تطلعاتهم إلى
إقامة دولة، ويحافظ الأردن على
استقلاله ويعزز
أمنه القومي. وأعتقد حقًا أنه في ظل
هذا الإطار فقط سوف
تنمو وتزدهر الدول الثلاث في سلام
وسلام واستقرار إقليمي أوسع.